Reino Unido reafirma su compromiso con
Ucrania el nuevo Primer Ministro
británico risis unac visitó kiev para
reunirse con el presidente ucraniano
bolodimir zelensky
informe al Señor Primer Ministro sobre
las consecuencias de los ataques con
cohetes rusos a partir de ahora
aproximadamente la mitad de la
infraestructura energética de Ucrania ha
resultado dañada
Reino Unido ya ha brindado más de 2.700
millones de dólares en apoyo militar y
para evitar esos ataques aéreos contra
la infraestructura clave Se comprometió
a otorgar 120 armas antiaéreas equipos
de radar y antidrones además de ayuda
humanitaria para el frío del Invierno
es una lección de humildad de estar hoy
con ustedes en su país el coraje del
pueblo ucraniano es una inspiración para
el mundo en los próximos años les
contaremos a nuestros nietos su historia
como el pueblo orgulloso y soberano se
puso de pie frente un ataque atrás como
luchó cómo se sacrificó cómo prevaleció
pero la guerra no cesa Rusia está
atacando las instalaciones eléctricas
dejando la mitad de kiev a oscuras
mientras los ojos continúan en gerson
después de que la universidad de Yale
publicase un informe respaldado por el
Departamento de estado estadounidense
que asegura que cientos de personas
fueron detenidas o desaparecieron
mientras la ciudad estuvo bajo control
del kremlin esta semana se había temido
la posibilidad de una escalada del
conflicto después de que un misil
golpeara territorio polaco pero todo
indicaba que fue un error de la defensa
antiaérea ucraniana este sábado se llevó
a cabo un funeral con honores por una de
las dos víctimas mortales
[Música]